[Music]
imagine a version of earth 50 million
years in the future one where humanity
has vanished and
extraordinary new creatures now populate
the planet
this hypothetical future is the topic of
the speculative zoology book
after man written by a founder of the
genre
doug dixon the book is part of a trilogy
alongside
man after man and the new dinosaurs i
have a video on the new dinosaurs
elsewhere in the archive but after man
is dixon's original masterwork and an
influence behind other series like
the future is wild and cm cozman's
infamous all tomorrows
its impact is no surprise as the
post-human earth dixon brings to life
within the pages
feels so familiar and yet so alien
and the biology of the futuristic
animals he showcases are so
strange it's worth taking a closer look
so
for this entry into the archive we're
going to break down the animal
ecosystems of the far future bearing in
mind that
as i mentioned in my new dinosaurs video
some of the science is outdated and it's
impossible to know exactly what such a
world would look like
think of this book and this video as
just an interesting guess
so let's leap forward 50 million years
and discover what fantastic species
might now reign over the planet
beginning in the vast temperate forests
and grasslands of this reborn earth the
planet's biome distribution has shifted
dramatically
50 million years from now tectonic
movements will likely rearrange the
continents pushing africa
into eurasia eurasia into north america
and separating north and south america
in these new transcontinental regions
dixon imagines you can find
various species of rabbits sizeable
swift-footed grazers with
strange appearances as you can imagine
rabbuks are descended from modern day
rabbits but have become much
larger with longer legs this is because
the rabbits
now occupy the same evolutionary grazing
niche once held by deer
which have declined in this hypothetical
future the rabbits are preyed upon by
the phalanx
a mid-sized predator species with
scissor-like molars
these carnivores are roughly wolf-sized
despite this however
the phalanx aren't the descendants of
wolves at all but a very distant
offshoot of none other than the rat and
i will say
i'm certainly glad that wolf-sized rats
aren't something we have to deal with in
our time
moving into the forests you can find the
oak leaf toad
one of my personal favorite new species
these curious amphibians get their name
from the peculiar leaf-shaped growth on
their back
which helps with camouflage many modern
toads employ camouflage of their own
though few at the same remarkable level
as the oak leaf
another way oak leaf toads are different
from most modern amphibians is that
they're true carnivores
large enough to eat small mammals
instead of just
insects and within the nearby wetlands
the bazaar
reed still lurks searching for prey with
its sinuous neck and balancing on its
platform-like
feet despite appearances the reed stilt
is
actually a descendant of insectivores
like hedgehogs
over millions of years these animals
lost their quills and became larger and
larger as they transitioned into
mid-sized predators
continuing on to the pine trees of the
northern coniferous forests
we have the hornheads a large animal
with unique horns for defense
which subsists off moss and lichen these
species are a larger more defensive
incarnation of the antelope
trading the characteristic speed of
their ancestors for size and security
from predators and speaking of predators
the pam threat is among the most
dangerous within the coniferous forest
these creatures are descended from
ferrets who are also carnivores in the
modern day
just not quite as dangerous ones but
even the pam threat sometimes think
twice about tangling with this next
animal
the spine-tailed squirrel as you can
tell by the name
they're most closely related to modern
ground squirrels although they've taken
a page out of the porcupine's handbook
and now sport long pointy quills for
warding off predators
a creative and effective survival
strategy
moving even further northwards we arrive
at the windswept tundra in below polar
regions
here you can find the woolly gigantelope
a thick-furred beast with
massive forward-facing horns for
clearing snow off the vegetation it
consumes
as you can likely tell by the name this
species is another offshoot of the
modern antelope
although its lumbering size and massive
horns make it
in many ways similar to a rhino in the
nearby icy mountains dwell the
sure-footed gorath
a species well-equipped for vertical
movement upon the steep slopes
this high elevation species is likely
the descendant of none other than the
goat
with the horns of the modern goat the
precursor to the single bony plate the
korath uses for territorial displays
and even further north within the icy
waters of what we
call the arctic circle the
leviathan-sized
vortex and smaller porpin swim through
the cold waters
the vortex is the new largest creature
on planet earth
and a clear analog to whales while the
poor pin shares many similarities to the
modern porpoise or dolphin
despite this the two animals are in fact
descended from none other than
penguins who over eons became fully
aquatic
and swelled to unfathomable sizes
so we've got more fantastical creatures
to cover including my personal favorite
but since we're halfway through the list
if you're enjoying this content please
consider taking a moment to like
subscribe and hit the notification icon
to stay up to date on all things curious
continuing on heading much further south
to the equator we find a vast sequence
of deserts
here dixon imagines the rather
unfortunate looking desert leapers
roam the sands these bulbous tailed
animals look
and hop like kangaroos but they're
actually another descendant of modern
rodents
the desert leaper also employs the same
unique survival strategy as the camel as
the creature's large
tail like a camel's hump contains
specialized fat deposits which allow it
to go without food for long periods
even more wrinkly than the desert leaper
is the desert shark
an animal with a truly unfortunate
appearance their hairless bodies are
carry over from their similarly alarming
looking ancestor
the naked mole rats and like naked mole
rats the sand sharks which have no
relation to actual sharks
spend most of their time burrowing
underground to regulate body temperature
and the last creature in the desert is
the root sucker a much friendlier
looking fellow with hard plates for
defense and long front claws for digging
up the roots of the succulents it feeds
on
the root sucker is the evolutionary
legacy of the armadillo
an animal that shares its armored shell
and also uses its front claws for
digging for food
so you can kind of understand where the
lineage comes from
continuing on also near the equator a
belt of tropical grasslands flourishes
in a climate similar to what supports
elephant populations today but instead
of elephants
the lumbering rundy horn and southern
gigantelope now
dominate the grassy fields both species
occupy a similar niche to modern
elephants as the heaviest land animals
on the new savannah
and perhaps the heaviest land animals
anywhere in this new world
as the name implies these species are
yet another descendant of the antelope
if you can believe it
but where there are grazers there are
predators and the horrain are a truly
bizarre looking species which preys on
the gigantelope and rundy horn
despite the build and overall coloring
of their bodies almost resembling that
of a modern cheetah
as you can probably tell by the faces
the hurran
are a descendant of primates which have
become fully carnivorous ambush
predators
and even more horrifying are the raboons
another primate offshoot which became a
grass-dwelling carnivore
descendants of the modern much less
frightening looking baboon
the raboons are no longer content to
feed on plants and fruit alone
becoming full-on scavengers like their
baboon ancestors however
they have a close family structure and
live in groups instead of going it alone
further south in the vast tropical
forests of the world
the long trunk to zarander feed on the
high leafy branches
despite their trunks the zarander aren't
actually related to elephants but to
modern day wild boars
it's hard to see the family resemblance
but 50 million years is a lot of time
for a species to adapt to a new way of
life
traveling along to tropical rivers we've
got the swimming monkey
the name kind of tells you everything
you need to know about this one they're
a monkey
but they're good at swimming a pretty
straightforward creature
and in the same boat we have the
swimming anteater
which once again is an anteater but
good at swimming you get it much more
unique
is the unfortunately named mud gulper a
species which occupies a similar niche
in the swampy waters as the modern day
hippopotamus
but despite having a very similar
looking snout the mud gulper is yet
another animal descended from a species
of rodent
in arriving at our final destination we
have the isolated and diverse world
of islands in particular the enormous
island of lemuria which broke off from
the modern african continent
is home to some of the most striking
species this new world has to offer
meet the night stalker an animal so
strange it twists
one's mind just looking at it the
four-limbed predatory nightstalker
is a descendant of the bat and has given
up the wings of its ancestors in favor
of a fully terrestrial existence
but the night stalker isn't the only
descendant of the bat worth mentioning
the last species on our list is the
fluer
an absolutely absurd looking animal
which resembles a flower in sight and
smell to lure in
insects crazy though this might seem
it's not actually that far
off from how venus fly traps catch their
prey in the modern day
although such a trait evolving in an
animal species
is a truly unusual concept and for that
reason
despite its appearance it's my personal
favorite
and that's the end of our voyage 50
million years into the future
like i said in my new dinosaurs video
doug dixon's work
while just an entertaining guess at the
future is worth checking out if you ever
get the chance
in the meantime thanks for watching if
you like this video please lend your
support
and like subscribe and hit the
notification icon if you haven't already
to stay up to date
on all things curious see you in the
next video
[Music]
you